alright last week Donald Trump lied to
us about rescheduling that Russian
hacking briefing from Tuesday to Friday
it wasn't true it was never scheduled
for Tuesday it was always scheduled for
Friday of course Donald Trump has been
denying that Russia did the hacking for
month after month after month the
briefing happened and now what do you
think happened now big surprise Donald
Trump now accepts the findings of the
intelligence community that Russia did
do the hacking as per rinse Priebus on
Fox News Sunday the nation's Intel
Chiefs laid out the full classified
report to president elect Trump and
others and his team including you right
Russian President Putin ordered a cyber
attack to interfere with the election
and eventually came to try to help
Donald Trump simple question does the
president-elect accept the findings and
the evidence of the intelligence
community well I think he accepts the
the findings Chris but here's the thing
that I think everyone needs to
understand when when this whole thing
started it started from the Russians 50
years ago in other words this is
something that's been going on in our
elections for many many years both the
Russians that show so he accepts it but
the new narrative is it's nothing new
it's nothing notable it's been going on
for a long time so we went Pat from
outright denials and skepticism from
Trump about Russian involvement in this
hacking to yeah he accepts it but it's
no big deal it's nothing new it's not
notable it's just that you know it
didn't change the outcome of the
election and later on rinse Priebus went
on to say that it's also the DNC's fault
that the hacking happened this is a
hundred and eighty degree reversal and
the trumpets seem to be in a fantasy
world as if nothing has changed Trump
accepts now that Russia did the hacking
he just says it doesn't matter yeah
Donald Trump is a very interesting
character in
at all sent very highly of in himself in
his own opinions and he's willing to
take his own ego out of over the
intelligence community that is going to
take over yeah but then on the other
side you have this guy who's kind of
willing to be persuaded he's open to
interpretation and its really
interesting having him resolve those two
sides on the one hand he knows better
than everybody else on the other hand he
believes whatever someone told him five
minutes ago until someone speaks to him
two minutes ago and tells them something
else so the key points which now Donald
Trump accepts from these this
Declassified version of a highly
classified investigation into this
Russian hacking Russian President
Vladimir Putin ordered an influence
campaign to undermine public faith in
the US democratic process the goal was
also to hurt Hillary Clinton harm her
electability later it became clear to
the American intelligence community that
Russia and Putin we're now going beyond
just wanting to hurt Hillary Clinton but
actually developing a preference for
Donald Trump and later we learned that
when it seemed as though Hillary Clinton
was going to win some of the the focus
from this Russian campaign shifted from
undermining the entire process to
preemptively undermining what they
believed to be an upcoming Hillary
Clinton presidency okay so now what well
nothing I guess we can never
definitively prove something that didn't
happen we can't ever really know whether
Hillary Clinton would have won were not
for Russian involvement also really
important let me remind you from last
week the way in which Julian Assange had
denied a connection between Russia and
these leaks remember this to Sean
Hannity Russia and Russia cyber
criminals with a political agenda of
influencing the election and obviously
they're talking not just about the John
Podesta emails the DNC emails but in
other ways I've asked you before I'll
ask you again today did Russia give you
this information or anybody associated
with Russia al sauce is not a state
party so
the answer for our interactions is not
as I said last week listen to the words
our source is not a state party so the
answer for our interactions is no well
my hypothesis was revealed to be true by
the analysis uh released by this report
that we've now gotten Declassified
report in conjunction with the briefing
that president-elect Donald Trump
received indeed an intermediary between
Russia and wick WikiLeaks has been found
which means that the letter of what
Julian Assange said is absolutely true
but the spirit of what Julian Assange
said is absolutely false US intelligence
officials identified intermediaries that
Russia used to get all of the hacked
data to WikiLeaks it's amazing Pat I
mean I I know that there's some people
in our audience who will just deny this
no matter what I picked up on the the
meaning of the specific words Julian
Assange was using and indeed that
analysis according to our intelligence
reports turned out to be true yeah you
could tell what Julian Assange was
saying there was very well thought out
very calculated and I think Donald Trump
realized he was in bad company now
having to agree with Julian Assange am
having to denounce his own intelligence
community so you can see why he backed
down eventually